can we get a motion to never be allowed  to adjourn until this is resolved that's  what I'd vote for I beg no one's leaving  their job is basically to sit around as  it is is like the easiest look right now  there's some dude loading bags into a  truck loading boxes into a Truck heavy  lifting covered in sweat his back is  hurting and is getting paid less than  these people to sit around and complain  about each other this is why I'm afraid  or concerned about leaving it up to the  con to the house to find their own  speaker because they are going to break  each other's will and then just brow  beat people down to like okay fine I  don't care anymore take it take whoever  you want that's not the way you elect  leadership we need the people deciding  who is going to be the voice of that of  that movement